today we want to see a blade that's born
of Pure Imagination so in the first
round of competition we'd like you to
use your imagination to forge for us a
fantasy blade that is between 12 and 14
inches in length since you're making out
of this world blades
here's some out of this world metal to
deal with
that is meteorite gentlemen you must
combine this meteorite that is entirely
mild steel with 1095 powder to create a
canister Damascus Billet from which to
forge your blades fancy blade okay
canister
not ideal meteorite
I have no clue good luck blade Smiths
your 10 minute design window Starts Now
fantasies are hard because I don't watch
fantasy TV or nothing like that but I'm
trying to
put a fish design a fishtail on my
drawing and have a swell in the middle
you know this could be my fantasy a fish
mouth
I don't make fantasy blades but I came
unfortunate fire to win so I'm going
extreme I'm designing something that I
can see an alien carrying in however
many years
I was thinking this curved blade with a
handle on the back
it is way outside of the box they said
fantasy I made them fantasy
oh my God I love fantasy blades I make
those all the time so it should be easy
right
I started out making this plate as a
viking blade so I'm going for a space
Viking theme
so my blade was designed to kill
three-headed tentacled purple aliens
from Scotland
it's my realm I can do what I want your
three hour Forge time starts
one of my
new
the only way is to jump in there and do
it
I put white out in my canister to start
with purpose of the white out is to try
to get the 1095 not to stick so you can
cut it off pretty easy and I know it's
in soft metal so I don't want the meteor
close to the edge
the time limit is not affected right now
as long as I get my weld to work
people waste a ton of time liquid
tapering waiting for it to dry and then
trying to remove that can and a lot of
times they stick anywhere so I'm not
taking the Caster off I'm just gonna
Forge that soft skill right in there and
grind it off at the end so I have a
hardenable edge
I know 1095 is horrible so I'm putting
it meteor in the middle I need
hardenable Steel on the edge of my knife
because it's not hardenable it will stay
soft and in the testing it will get
damaged to make my canister I'm going to
use pieces of meteorite and I'm going to
put them in the bottom and try and get
them to be the spine of the knife and
I'm going to put in the 1095 powder I'm
doing it this way so that I know that my
mild steel be in one's part of the
Billet and it'll be high carbon in the
rest I get my can packed up welded and
into the forge it goes it's time to
start drawing this thing out Chris is
looking good now he has to draw fill it
out that's a lot longer
longer to get this blade at 14 inches I
have to make my bill at 26 inches long
that is a long village
sword with that I think it's going to be
wild
I think is going to be a question in
everybody's Minds here we get to be part
of the fantasy we get to make up how to
use a thing in the can or strong Mr
moment is my biggest concern I think
that what he's done is he's drawn out
that Billet so peeling this is going to
be a challenge
there you go I realize that I have no
idea where my meteorite is
I don't remember which side I put the
high carbon on
if that meteorites on the edge then the
blade won't Harden without a hardened
Edge it won't cut it won't slice it'll
be useless
when you etch your Blade the acid is
just eating away at the weaker steel so
the meteorite is going to be lighter
than the 1095 hopefully it's on the
spine and not on the edge
now we can see where everything is
the nice thing about having that
meteorite with that much Nickel in it it
should pop pretty pretty brightly
oh that's a shame so he's got mild Steel
on his Edge and some high carbon steel
my blade is meteorite 1095 and they both
meet at the edge
it's a big deal because if both edges
aren't hard the blade will deform it'll
break
there's really no way for me to fix it
I just hope it doesn't break
weird bang pale it looks getting ready
it's an alien story
I want to quench just the edge but the
quench tank won't allow that so I'm
going to have to quench the whole blade
I want that play to be hard I want that
blade to be straight
it's not hard
start the freak out a little bit then I
think
that canister is still on that blade of
course it's not hard so that was an aha
moment
all right look at that Randy's getting
ready to quench perfect
here we go yeah
I've got a good hard straight blade and
I'm tickled it's impossible to State how
much that clock will mess with your head
Dan he's got his shape ground in because
my blade is meteorite 1095 when it gets
quenched the 1095 constricts so the
blade gets a bow in it stupid blade so
the goal is to have as little warp as
possible
I'm gonna punch this blade as many times
as I have to until it comes into a range
where I know I can fix it
five four three two one this first round
of competition is open
late Smiths welcome to the strength test
to test the strength and durability of
your blades as well as the overall
construction of your fantasy knives I
will be chopping them into this odd
looking armor remember this test is all
about what the armor does to your blades
and not what your blades do to the armor
Dan you're up first you ready yep all
right
oh God this is the worst dealing ever my
stomach just went up to my throat half
my Edge is high carbon steel and the
other half is meteorite it looks good
but I don't think it's gonna hold up
well then first things first your knife
held together everything's still tight
there's no wiggling The Edge however
there's three major sections of
deformation you can see the steel is
sticking up pretty high here it's kind
of curled around
that all being said I think you did a
really interesting fantasy looking blade
and this part up here where it becomes
big and proud it really penetrated the
armor really well right there
it's interesting looking and functional
at the same time so well done thank you
Randy you're up how you feeling not
really really yeah we're gonna do it
anyway
I'm a little worried Dan's blade took a
lot of damage and I feel like I may be
right there with him uh I want to close
my eyes and I just don't want to look
foreign
well Randy this is a it's got a lot of
Mass to this thing this is a heavy knife
your blade held up really well there's
some minor chipping here and here but
the edge geometry put on that is perfect
for a chopping test like this
the handle is comfortable to hold
but it is a little bit easy to lose
control for that aside I like that you
used the meteorite for the guard I think
it really adds to the fantasy nature of
the knife so and all well done thank you
Chris you're up next are you ready I'm
ready I'm excited to swing this thing
my knees are shaking my palm is sweating
my heart is thumping what I'm worried
about is my design
I've never seen one like my blade
come on Chris this is why I wore a glove
I'm kind of stuck in there
for the first couple Sprites it was fun
to swing I'll give you that that's for
sure
um it is bent up this way here but more
importantly right down here where the
blade meets the handle is where it
pulled away from the guard at that spot
I'm guessing your Tang right there is
just wasn't wide enough to support this
amount of stress and the whole handle
moved over and I just don't feel
comfortable testing this weapon anymore
I understand
all right Chris of all of our smiths in
this competition you Embrace this
challenge the most wholeheartedly but
unfortunately it presents a clear and
present danger to the end user and for
that reason we cannot continue testing
your blade and I have to ask you to
please leave the forge
with my design I embraced that challenge
my son and I have a very competitive
bladesmithing relationship we compete
all the time so me wants to come to Ford
and fire when he turns 18. I sold a
pretty big bar for him to meet but I'm
excited for him to get this experience
first thing I do when I get home is I'm
going to hug my wife and kiss my dog but
I don't have a dog or a wife